voilà chers amis et bravo à daniel pour
un ancien l'ancien trésorier que je suis
c'est un exploit d'avoir réussi à faire
payer l'ensemble des élus est une bonne
chose et c'était absolument nécessaire
pour assurer la coordination tout
simplement la cohérence et la discipline
au sein de notre mouvement je sais que
les militants ils sont évidemment
attacher les conventions le projet du
parti c'est un point indispensable
il n'y a pas de grands partis sans
grands projets sans projet aujourd'hui
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
le projet des républiques à vous le
savez vous êtes appelés et les
fédérations sont appelés les militants
sont appelés à se prononcer sur le
projet au fur et à mesure de son
élaboration
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un projet un
projet c'est d'abord un programme c'est
des mesures c'est des mesures en
fonction d'un certain nombre de thèmes
l'économie le social la défense les
sécurités ce programme nous sommes en
train de constituer
mais le programme c'est pas suffisant un
projet c'est plus que ça un projet c'est
aussi un sens c'est donner du sens à
notre action se mettre des mots sur nos
valeurs c'est de faire ensemble qu'on
partage ensemble une série de
propositions plus que ça qu'on partage
ensemble l'avenir de notre pays tous
aient une signification pour les
français et que ce ne soit pas
évidemment que des mesures d'ordre
technique technocratique ou
bureaucratiques c'est plus que cela et
on essaie de faire en sorte que ce soir
plus que cela le calendrier du projet il
est en marche
nous avons commencé sous l'autorité de
nicolas sarkozy nous avons commencé à y
travailler il ya des conventions qui se
succèdent et puis on ira comme ça jusqu
à l'été et à l'été il y aura la
publication d'un document
d'ores et déjà on vous a distribué ce
petit document et je vous incite à le
regarder il est sur vos tables et ce
document il fait le résumé des
différentes conventions qui ont eu lieu
jusqu'à présent
vous y trouverez à la fois des
diagnostics et vous y trouverez aussi
des des propositions ces conventions
pour le moment elles ont été elles ont
passé en revue les problèmes de logement
que dire du logement social
que dire du coût du logement en france
que dire des normes qui affecte la
construction du logement souvent plus
importante que dans d'autres sur
d'autres dans d'autres pays on verra
d'ailleurs que c'est un sujet qui veut
pour à beaucoup d'autres sujets que dire
de la fiscalité du logement
et puis après on a parlé de de sécurité
et d'immigration sujets qui sont au
coeur des préoccupations des français
l'immigration c'est évidemment schengen
c'est l'europe c'est les politiques
européennes
c'est la crise des migrants qui frappe
aujourd'hui l'europe qui frappe notre
pays qui frappe l'ensemble des pays
d'europe
et puis évidemment c'est la possibilité
de définir des plafonds d'immigration
c'est la nécessité d'intégration avant
l'indispensable assimilation des
personnes qui rejoignent notre sol et
puis c'est évidemment les questions
nationalité tous ces sujets ont fait
l'objet de débats approfondis et puis on
a travaillé sur la sécurité
on a travaillé sur le code du travail
voulait encore un sujet majeur
tout le monde en parle aujourd'hui du
code du travail et la politique du
travail du marché du travail qui au fond
est devenu une sorte de marché du
chômage
à force de rigidité le marché du travail
y crée du chômage
lui même s'est pas uniquement un
problème de croissance et vous devrez
j'espère en tout cas lire ce qui a été
indiqué partager ce qui a été dit et
puis nous avons également enfin il ya
maintenant une semaine
essayer de travailler avec nos amis
agriculteurs sur l'agriculture dans
quelques semaines dans quelques jours il
y aura un salon de l'agriculture
ici la porte de versailles on voit bien
que françois hollande tente de sauver la
mise juste avant l'ouverture du salon de
l'agriculture
il aura bien du mal compte tenu de
l'état désastreux de l'agriculture
française on a essayé de dire aux
agriculteurs que c'était des
entrepreneurs les agriculteurs sont des
entrepreneurs et doivent être traités
comme cela et puis nous avons parlé de
ruralité cette ruralité
si déboussolés si désarçonné qui se
cherche si inquiète pour son avenir et
nous avons essayé de proposer des
solutions fortes nicolas sarkozy a parlé
de plan marshall sur la ruralité
voilà autant de sujets qui sont mis au
débat
l'ensemble de ces conventions font
l'objet d'un vote vous êtes très
nombreux à voter jusqu'à 50 ou 60 huile
selon les questions qui sont posées et
nous allons continuer ainsi d'autres
conventions vont venir
on en parlera j'imagine tout au long de
ces deux journées on parlera d'économie
on parlera d'emplois on parla de
protection sociale on parlera de défense
nationale on parlera de cette france qui
est en train de se dessiner cette france
qui vient la france du numérique le
socle de cette france qui vient c'est à
dire nos nos familles on parlera
évidemment de politique étrangère on
parlera de justice en parlera de
fiscalité
tous ces sujets là sans tabou seront
abordés et font l'objet de propositions
des groupes de travail vous pouvez venir
dans ces groupes de travail des groupes
de travail préparent ce travail les
militants votent
bref tout ça c'est la démocratie pour un
nouveau projet alors on doit le
construire ensemble et je voudrais
terminer par ça nous avons sur nos sites
internet des républicains la possibilité
de prendre l'ensemble des contributions
des français plus largement d'ailleurs
que celle de nos militants plus de 2000
contribution été déposée et ses
contributions elles doivent permettre de
forger le projet dans un aller-retour
entre ceux qui sont experts d'un sujet
et ceux qui ont envie de s'exprimer
entre ceux qui sont connus sur un sujet
et ceux qui sont des anonymes
tout cela fait l'ensemble des deux
propositions qui seront qui sont les
nôtres et je voudrais vraiment vous
puissiez participer
et puis on ira dans dans vos
départements on ira dans vos fédérations
nous viendront expliquer propos j'ai
discuté débattre tous les secrétaires
nationaux tous les délégués généraux
viendront et participeront à
l'organisation de ce vaste mouvement
quel projet alors peut-il y avoir une
primaire et un projet pour les
républicains
c'est peut-être un sujet
on abordera un petit peu plus tard
évidemment il peut y avoir à la fois une
primaire est à la fois un projet pour
les républicains il n'y a pas de partie
sans projet le parti il est il et il
n'est pas lié à l'actualité la primaire
n'écrase pas me semble-t-il le parti au
contraire le parti
il doit pouvoir définir ce qui nous
rassemble nous les militants des
républicains les deux cent cinquante
mille militants des républicains nous
partageons des valeurs nous partageons
des idées nous avons une certaine idée
de l'avenir de notre pays comme de
l'avenir de l'europe
et si cela que nous exprimerons dans ce
projet qui sera soumis évidemment à
votre vote d'ici l'été